And the correct answer here is O(2nn²) and the reason why this is correct is as follows--
so the first line here takes constant amount of times so that's not going to be relevant.
Now, this loop here lines 2 to 5 are executed 2n, so the question is each time this interloop here
lines 3 to 5 is executed, how much time does that take.
So checking of the assignment is valid, takes O(2n²), then if the assignment is valid,
we need an additional O(n)+O(1), so an additional O(n) time because this here is constant,
so we can ignore it.
So the maximum time that lines 3 to 5 take is O(n²)+O(n)+O(1),
so the largest growing term here is O(n²)--so the interloop takes O(n²) and that is executed 2n.
So that's why the running time of Alice's algorithm is O(2nn²),
and the good thing is that because we have our own notation, we could do this analysis
without actually concretely stating how all of these algorithm is programmed.
So as I hoped you see, it's quite a useful notation to have.